after you've started to see videos
performing really well
you want to start repurposing that
content on other platforms
so paid media is a really good place to
turn to with our first video that hit a
million views
we decided to take that video and
retarget people that visited our website
on facebook and instagram and we figured
that if people were coming over to our
website or we're seeing a spurt and
we're also seeing a
large growth in views on tech talk as
well they're most likely very correlated
so that gave us an opportunity to
retarget people
that had visited our website but didn't
actually hit that application button
you can also take this content and
repurpose it on instagram reels
on tiktok instead of saving and
downloading the video like
it gives you the option to you can
actually save the video as a live
photo and then convert it to a video in
your photo library
and instead of having a big tick tock
logo on the side of the video it'll
actually just put a little logo
at the bottom and that makes it a lot
easier to share it on other platforms
like instagram reels or on your
instagram story
instagram reels is very similar to tick
tock it'll show content in the same way
to people that are viewing that platform
and it's just another place to post
content